purring and you ready hello everybody
and welcome to in sensitivity training
I'm court McGowan I'm Joe Clark Nick
here we are buddy Phoenix yeah man uh
but this there's more people in this
room than actually listen to the podcast
abso-fucking-lutely the greatest fan TAS
are largest audience ever exactly
yeah we're here hey even Phoenix I used
to live here for like nine months why
tell us about that [ __ ] would you live
in this high put Midas this is where I
put my name on the wall for drinking 340
beers of the world in two months and ten
days Jesus how many did you drink on the
flight coming out here though on the
flight nut I'd like ten guinnesses and
like ten shots a crown at Paddy's yeah
but hey Matt feel strong here hey you
but Jesus Christ God oh no you have our
own podcast what's my name guys Matt
Voltron the full charge I can't I can't
wait for a guy that was booked 10
minutes ago you have a lot of attitude
oh I will be back on the plane you know
you have a crazy life when you land at
JFK and you're already getting eight
notices to check in for the flight for
tomorrow yeah I finally used the like
use the phone to check-in and I have to
get the piece of paper I've done that
before yeah it's scary because I'm
always afraid to look like the TSA
lady's like from the TV hey well anyway
we go syrup overs we have the great
poverty late mr. versi good to see you
buddy I wasn't gonna just jump in but I
felt you like if didn't feel like they
were waiting a little bit like I was no
but I just felt like I'm a listener I
wanted to tell them what I wanted to
hear
oh they do like Joe's got the story
about how he was up all night last night
yeah well my usual my usual New York
travel is I drink until I have to get
into the I usually take a subway but I
was too drunk to like when to deal with
the subway yeah so I got a lift I would
love to see your face at JFK Hamrick
last night because I know you didn't
sleep you know I never see but the cool
thing was like I took like I took three
Tylenol PM so I just woke up in Phoenix
it was like time traveling I don't know
if I can you feel when you
walked off the plane though Oh terrible
ID to go sit down in the airport just
like sit down and like stretch out real
are you like you're like look look
around going do I have my luggage do I
not have my life literally for a second
thought I was in Vegas business every
time I'm in Phoenix I think I'm
somewhere else the one one time I was in
Phoenix I got so drunk at my opening for
Lisa Lampanelli Matt was there
Matt Matt komen the area my glasses on
how you doing there so uh it was so
funny because I'll never forget this
because it was uh we did Long Beach
great show came here and then we did we
did someplace right around here some big
theater and people would stand up live
for like hey come to a set come to a set
I'm sure I drink my bottle crown I
usually drink and I got like and I
started drinking something standing up
alive and I'm like oh my god I'm like I
got to get out of here and I just left
next thing I know I woke up on the roof
of my hotel
the crazy thing what it is but I didn't
the thing was was the I guess I found
that later the elevator was out so
somehow I walked up six flights of
stairs I would have liked to seen that
but when I woke up the funny thing was
if you know Phoenix anyone here knows
Phoenix if they kind of have two
skylines uh-huh so when I woke up I
didn't know what [ __ ] city I was in I
could I didn't recognize any of the
skylines I'm like oh my god I slept
through the whole show I'm [ __ ] I go
downstairs and I leg in my bed something
like 135 degrees outside so I had the
worst leg cramp and I later better
stretch my leg away if you take me Paul
in court out of this I had the worst is
like an Amy Jo speaking right now I had
the worst no so then and I so then fans
gave me weed so I still had some weed
left so I went outside smoke this big
joint I had one left and I gave it to
Lady the front desk I go do you smoke
she goes yeah I gave it to her and then
she came back with two huge things to
watch because you like you need these
and you can ask Kevin Shea I was so
hungover that next day he took me to the
Dodger game because I'm never singing
that drink before I'm like dude I got
lit up in Phoenix Phoenix is a great
drink in town I should be part of like
the sponsorship here or the good it's a
good time to be dehydrated in I know
that much yeah I'm sorry nothing you
guys what what's funny is I I tell the
story but these are my favorite drinking
buddies the Lord cleaned up yeah but
course got the best ways of a mall so
you don't drink oh yeah what's that
you don't drink no not foods retired I
retire that's and that's a good way to
put it yeah I get hired you hung it up I
didn't quit I retired so I am Barry
Sanders when it comes to booze and drugs
I rush for the most yards in the fewest
amount of years anybody in his
all-purpose yards all-purpose [ __ ] how
long how many years been clean uh
16 Oh Congrats yeah I'm 74 so you know
great I do I feel good I'm 74 but it's
best looking man in podcast and there we
go Joe I got to tell you something I was
on the put you know I had a miserable
playing experience today but I thought
about when me and you were in first
class and you don't remember the story
I'm new yeah go ahead
yeah so we're uh we got first class and
I'm I love to you know I love to get the
perks of first-class mr. anemones yeah I
love I love amenities amenities why did
you correct him I always liked that
slide because it makes him feel better
diversion come on Jesus Christ
so uh so no so we we fly we fly into
what city did were we in when we Joe
Gonzales was with us - where do we fly
in and well we flew in land our land and
the Duke knows Atlanta it was Atlanta
yeah because we watch Duke in it was in
North Carolina so we fly into Atlanta
first class I have two cocktails before
they taxi like at the beginning so I'm
loving this [ __ ] so I'm thinking that's
what's gonna happen
that's what's gonna happen next so
unbeknownst to me Joe is sitting next to
me in first class on the way out so like
this is [ __ ] great
I'm sitting next to my buddy we're gonna
have some cocktails before we even
attack
see out I'm excited I really am so all
of a sudden like this tall guy who was
the flight attendant he's like looking
around he didn't look right
and he's like looks like a terrorist
yeah he's and he's like no not not like
not with the beard and he just looked
like he was up to some you just had
something on his something was wrong and
he was like looking around and people
and use on his shoe you just kept
looking around and I'm just going like
dark-skinned guy where's our [ __ ]
drink I'm like where's our first drink
you know he was getting a little yeah I
was like hotter the collar that we
didn't have for drinks in this before
little white yeah I've definitely become
where like when I go to a restaurant I
want [ __ ] water within yeah just you
know what I mean is there anything hey
someone knows paid for first class we
should get our drinks why not Joe
Gonzales did not waste his money yeah so
I start going to Joe I'm like we didn't
get it we didn't get a drink and then
all of a sudden I'm like they're gonna
start they're gonna start starting to
close the [ __ ] door here so we go
over to the guy and the guys I got man I
think I got maybe able to sneak you one
now but I don't know you may have to you
may have to wait so now not only do I
not get one two drinks I don't get one
drink they close the doors in some big
in some big ol black woman's like don't
give him nothing I could see she was
pissed
oh wow yeah like the the head waitress I
call them waitress says what if light
into their waitresses their waitress
yeah their janitorial waitstaff yes they
hung up your [ __ ] so uh so now I'm
pissed and I'm chirping in Joe's ear I'm
like this is [ __ ] what the [ __ ] am i
sit in first-class port if I can't have
[ __ ] a drink before I get out of here
you know we got only a two-hour flight
so now so now and now I'm gonna look
like an alcoholic trying to like get in
as many as I can from Atlanta to New
York which is an hour and 20 minutes so
I'm pissed off and the guy comes over
and he just goes Joe he goes I go yeah I
go out good I've got a screwdriver I'll
get a vodka orange and Joe goes yeah can
I get a seven and seven and he just
stares at Joe and he goes I'm sorry I'm
new I don't know and Joe just goes uh
all right can I get it I get her beer
you know what you know I'll just get
what he's having
I'll just get what he's having so it's
not confusing right
guy goes in he comes out he gives us
these drinks after another five minutes
right we're not it's all it was a tough
recipe yeah
so during take off the dirty take we got
to drink after ticket during takeoff he
starts going up and he didn't secure the
trays and she you know the way they have
yeah yeah yeah I think so
as we're like angled up this [ __ ]
just silver tray just comes baby pinging
down pinging down and not missing a beat
Barton just goes he's new I'm [ __ ]
I'm [ __ ] crying I am crying laughing
right and Joe and we finally got our
drinks and the guy was really he was
really [ __ ] he sucked
we got one drink and I got like nine
more after that yeah I used to I used to
fly I remember if this was years and
years and years ago but they before 9/11
before other stuff but America West just
had this thing where you didn't have to
pay for your ticket to you got on the
plane
made the reservation really great huge
rain huh you'd write a check like for
your like I remember I was in college
and I was coming I was going from
Oklahoma to California and I and I got
on the plane I wrote a hot check it was
a hundred and eight dollars I never
forget this throat $108 hot check on
America West was free drinks so once you
got on the plane there was there was
free booze but for those that don't know
hot check is a check that's no good yeah
wrote a check for $108 no there's not
there's probably had 14 dollars in my
checking account but I got an 8-ball in
my pocket
and I get on the plane and I just start
yeah oh yeah I had money given I had
money before 1990 for rent
this was the good old days and so I get
on the plane and that don't need read
you can just stay up yeah I just stay up
sort by this starts out starts out with
like having a couple drinks and then
going to the bathroom and doing a couple
of bumps you know and then I hate doing
drugs in those little baths I know but
but after a while you know how you start
this their personality starts feeling
bigger and bigger and bigger cut to like
two hours later I'm standing in the
front of the plane with a cocktail just
[ __ ] drink
with [ __ ] everybody stand up they're
[ __ ] screaming and yelling stayed up
til I mean I mean I would by the time I
hit the [ __ ] tarmac in LAX I was
shit-faced I mean beyond shit-faced big
huge white coke stains and my [ __ ]
nose I get out to play my buddy picks me
up he's like dude you need to do
something about that I was like well in
10 years looks like you've been looks
like you just blew up in baby powder I
had these huge [ __ ] white things
stayed up til 5 o'clock in the morning
it was one of the so what happened with
this Czech man did you get enough money
[ __ ] him no it's stayed in California
with there's nothing so that's why the
terrorists won dude I could get on a
plane now with a [ __ ] 8-ball I could
there's there's nothing I mean it's it's
it's so easy you just put it in like I
know guys that still supply with joints
they just put them in airtight container
join yeah but it's the same thing it's
enable three and a half grams about
about this big it's about six and a half
everybody knows that math math I dunno
yeah speaking of which anyone any math
tutors out there oh my god my daughter
she's getting sent back to easier math
it's like why did he do that five [ __ ]
years ago all the money I spent in
tutors Wow this went a whole nother
Goshen just now I mean I hated school
when I went to school but now it's even
worse when your kids get to tell them
it's all [ __ ] it's like no yeah I
think I don't think I learned in college
is how to open a beer with a with a
lighter which you used to know now what
Bud Lights or Twitter I get this part is
sponsored by Bud Light oh how great
would it be watching hungover bartnick
doing his daughter's math just after
like a [ __ ] two-day bender in New
York just coming back hungover burning
but what's funny is is I got I have a
great full Tron story oh no what would I
liked why you said that when you looked
at your taxes this year there's like
I'll go ahead tell the story my taxes
this year and I found one receipt and it
was like $150 or something with this bar
I'm like I've never drank $150 worth of
booze and then I was like oh that was
you Sunday that was the night I went out
with partner like that was only one
round or something like you paid for
most of it yeah hey everyone's on
scholarship when Joey reason it was fun
it was a fun night
no it was a great time well the funny
thing well in San Francisco you were we
were what I was walking out come on I
was at this time I was really hungover
you know you know you're hungover when
the guy at the head shop that sells like
Grateful Dead t-shirts and then sense
goes oh man you look terrible I was
going in there to buy sunglasses oh I
remember you told me that yeah yes so I
was walking in to this bar just to get
like one drink before I went to get a
cheesesteak in North Beach and this kid
Grant Cotter was in there and he goes
hey he goes where's Joe I'm like what he
told me he's like he was walking right
behind you when you walked in so I
texted Joe and as soon as it said I go
oh [ __ ] i'mma be a really drunk during
the day you wouldn't even during the day
it was like a half an hour that rekt
know what for you oh yeah it was before
it was like 11:00 a.m. and I go I'll
come in but I have to write my pro
hockey news article so I'm like I'll
come in for like one drink then I'm
gonna leave so responsible with his
hockey [ __ ]
he could be [ __ ] he could be just
[ __ ] you know Blizzard drinking but I
gotta go I gotta go back to the hotel
take care of God take care of my hockey
thing this guy will be half-dead and do
his [ __ ] [ __ ] think that's a
professor a professional but you live
you live in New York I don't I think the
worst city to be hung over in his New
York was that because of the heat the
subways I was in I was when I lived in
New York when I lived in New York one
time I went out we went out to Jones
Beach for a concert yeah and I and I was
up til like 5:00 6:00 in the morning and
I used to work at this restaurant in
Midtown so I had this was like August so
I had to get out I lived in so high to
get up
I walk down into the subway and I was
carrying my restaurant shirt like on a
hanger that had like you know I got it
back from the cleaners yeah and I'm and
I walk into the subway on the C train
down at like Spring Street yeah when I
walk in it's so hot it's so disgusting
and I you know I've slept like maybe an
hour and I was just I was trying not to
throw up and I'm and I just finally get
on the train and you know when you get
on the train the cool air yeah the door
shuts the best my I'm on a packed train
on Sunday morning it's packed and all of
a sudden I just turned white is it ghost
tell me he threw up and people just
looked at me and I just go and I just
started throwing up on the train and
everyone just scattered and everyone
just scattered and I was like yeah I
guess that's one way to get a seat on a
train where's your retire quarter time
here's why being here's my New York is
the greatest city for being hungover in
because hey you can walk everywhere you
can walk forever home and be is the you
know egg bacon cheese on over hard roll
three bucks yeah to mention here the dog
is lying around on every block oh yeah
greet all Yingling East Coast beer yeah
although we're drinking Bud Light right
now the great beer thank you it really
is the best I love there's nothing like
a cold Bud Light is my really sponsor
okay yeah you just thought your love
about I do love Bud Light I drink I I
you know I put all those I drink I drink
three hundred and forty beers in Arizona
and when you drink that many beers you
know a shitty one yeah Tito's it was
three it was two months in ten days it
was it was it was in Scottsdale Arizona
I used to work doubles and then go drink
and my girlfriend at the time would just
drive me home yeah yeah are you gonna do
the how many how many 71 days how many
beers did you drink three hundred and
forty three forty divided by you yeah
that's about five beers that's about
Oh some things I do some things that do
like 10 some days I do like but they're
all like these huge beers like Germany
or in Ireland whatever what's funny we'd
make it like risk like today I'm taking
West Germany and drink like 10 of the 10
beers but there's there's like the
Hitler of drinking I am Churchill stop
me we lost a crowd what happened well we
had 5 people here we know drunken
stories like Joe stepping down because
of alcohol abuse skiers stepping down
his manager of the Diamondbacks is too
much that'd be great
[Music]
funny thing is if Joe was at a press
conference for having to step down for
too much drinking it would be the most
unapologetic white wine you queer
whiskey [ __ ] Daniels look em up
[ __ ] what do you feel about the fans
that you disappointed who loved your
managerial skills but don't like you
condone your alcohol abuse oh you're
asking me to figure out who he just
defended I pulled the Cam Newton III I
think that's a funny question coming
from abroad
I like how they gave him [ __ ] for that
though it's like it is funny some chicks
talking about past offense
it's like it is a stupid [ __ ]
question oh don't back down now full
tron this is in sensitivity training you
can't
I didn't bring you up here to go oh I
don't know no no no you're not allowed
to say anything anymore
Oh see get in trouble this show cuz we
say it no one listens if you have a good
time and if you have trouble with it all
you do is just kind of laugh
uncomfortably and go Oh Joe how about
this oh we like we host quark oh I light
it that one out actually in all the
years we've done the podcast I have only
edited at one time and that was more
because we just had a bat we had a bad
start and we were bored and other than
that I never added oh I got a question
I waited twice twice I waited it twice
and then once I don't last week because
we started talking by the Harvey
Weinstein thing and I'm like you know
this isn't going anywhere good don't
take Joe down that road just take this
[ __ ] down yeah any big job just any
podcast like Oh die before that'll be a
funeral but if I was if I was a you know
a reporter for something that women did
like if I was like reporting like a like
like women's figure skating and I was
like hey you know Cindy that double axel
when you did it and she just was like
it's kind of funny like a New York guy
like you were like a guy like you
talking about the I would laugh I'm like
I know they just [ __ ] this is what
they're paying me to do yeah I wouldn't
have I get I get the incent I get that
it was a little bit like but he didn't
like he didn't say anything like chick
or broad or like you know but the funny
thing is is now you see it like there's
there still I mean I still haven't I've
heard a like a national like NFL
broadcast like a Sunday game you know a
national broadcast game or a college
football game where they've had a woman
in the booth you know a woman sounds
like she's mugs like 10 Paul miles yeah
hey for Vince Evans like she's making
like she's eating [ __ ] before she's on
the mic I mean I mean I get that they
have I get that they have them doing
sideline reporting and I get that but I
mean that you can see their cleavage
the matarese thank you it's always
easier just to go yeah yeah yeah I agree
I agree courts made nine dollars doing
that victim culture right like it was
all it's my chance to be offended right
funny cuz the guy we like the president
was vulgar I was just talk I was just
talking I was talking to Morgan Murphy
earlier tonight we were talking about
how name-dropper yeah we were but we
were talking about how like I've worked
in Hollywood since 1984 and it was just
kind of common you know for years and
years and years now people are coming
out of the woodwork and they're caught
you know and it's like look I I'm not
saying that it's never have you weren't
pretty you wouldn't have all those jobs
exactly but I can't tell you how many
times back in the 80s when you were a
young good-looking man that men didn't
approach you and be like you know hey if
you did you know if you took care of me
like this you know I could that happen
to you you got you go [ __ ] yeah how do
you think I got camp on me love I sucked
a lot of men for that job
but no but I'm saying what do you think
separated Lauren Bacall from Lauren
whoever from down the street it's acting
it's not like a big oh my god you can't
do that sure you know reading from her
Wikipedia like Angie Dickinson would be
still be a secretary if it wasn't for
like it whatever the casting it's like
so stupid oh no she went to acting
school now she blew somebody that's what
she got in the movies like a massage for
a movie how far did you go I never I was
I was like the only time it ever really
happened to me was I had an acting
teacher who basically was like hey you
know if you kind of would you know kind
of hang out you wouldn't have to pay for
acting classes that's why I'm a shitty
actor hungover and you hung out but like
didn't know what he meant yes I guess so
what are we doing man he's like well
you're gonna be putting your lips around
my [ __ ] any minute now for your free
acting class no but I know words out
there cutting his grass
[Laughter]
but that was common I mean there's like
I mean I knew there was like I knew of
guys that got hit on by casting
directors by dude casting directors all
the [ __ ] time
and there was like certain cast
directors you knew were those guys and
you're like oh that's [ __ ] we that
[ __ ] happens everywhere it happens in
sports it happens everywhere it's just
Hollywood and movies is more glorified
and because it's its job but now it's
coming out everywhere there's some great
stories in the New York Post of
executives like what they're doing this
oh yeah hilarious what do you mean Joe
what are they doing oh just you know
like that's some big executive it
somewhere not somewhere like I just you
know I but there's gonna be a lot of
bodies floating know just like you know
all the stories when he's what he would
do to these chicks in his office it's
hilarious oh oh you mean Harvey no just
like some banker like I'm like you know
whatever I'm gonna say Citibank I don't
think it was Citibank he's just popped
in my head where the guy would like lock
chicks in the you know in the rooms and
all this crazy [ __ ] he's doing like in
an office like you remember hearing that
like in comedy in the 80s which you
weren't a part of here those stories I
remember hearing a story when I used to
work on the Universal Studios backlot we
were doing a show back there and they
were telling us about the guy back in
the day these tablets called the black
tower that overlooked the whole back lot
overlooked the whole studio like bear
Bryant's yeah Alabama and room and this
guy was like one of the heads of like
Universal and he would sit there and
they they would come in and they would
like bring him launch her they bring him
stuff and he would basically be sitting
at this big desk and he would just be
getting blown like throughout the whole
like he did a movie yeah well there's a
there's a famous story about Andy Rooney
that every day at lunch on the movie
sets you know that you know that [ __ ]
Andy Rooney Bert I did Bikram yoga for
years yes I I didn't make it competitive
I just did
improve myself I love Bert Kreischer
free beer back there Bert yeah live in
extra three days what we talk about Andy
Rooney used to call chicks he used to he
used to call his wife every lunch hour
while hooker blew him on the phone he
would do know the guy he was right at
the end of 60 minutes blowing that
[ __ ] guy yeah paper clips and rubber
bands rub my balls more broad Nero beat
the Giorno Voltron spy cast is the best
I love inversions of course is awesome
too but we do it you do a funny thing
now there's a whole channel devoted to
this on XM yeah what do I do I call it I
call it a you call it's rehab music or
boat music something hilarious cruise
rock what you call I call cruise rock
yeah because it's all that it's all that
seven these kind of where people do
drugs in the 60s and had like Ange
champagne yeah big baby still coming on
baby you do a name that tune yeah
basically that's there's maybe three
episodes of that before a Shaw you know
him yeah well for the great for show so
he's way into what they call Yacht rock
now which is soft rock and my day and I
could name every that's the thing you
think you can and it's kind of tough
I'll have to have you on court I can for
sure we'll see what we can does record
hey dick course everything from the 70s
racquetball yeah I still got a bunch of
wristbands did you talk about stuff well
you play racquetball like in the movies
or do you just be silent when you do
oh no no we've talked I was a good way
to progress them you would talk while
running yeah yeah you gotta talk and not
but I also had a headband to
eighties headband yes Oh late seventies
early eighties I started the headband
when stuff was it Mack and yarn Bork
your Borg was the first guy that liked
war they had McEnroe warm to Denis more
yeah when he after he got the big big
fro you know but but borg was like the
guy who wear the Fela headband and
wristbands and was that late 80s late
70s yeah late seventies early eighties
yeah he was amazed he on board was just
a [ __ ] hound God Almighty God oh yeah
the best thing in the world that he was
like a good looking man I'm I'm man
enough to I know when the guy's a
good-looking sure Swedish just [ __ ]
just crush an ass man yeah long long
golden locks he was a good-looking man
[ __ ] did McEnroe get I was he that
upset for a reason he married Patty
Smyth right the rocker the punk rock I
don't know who that chicken is I always
hear her name everywhere it's like who
the [ __ ] is patty Smith had a huge hit
with Tom Petty's song no it was here
come because the night belongs to
Lover's yeah that was a big one but
she's pretty song it was way too famous
that's the shitty song she was a CBGB
[ __ ] where they just talk about how
great it was blondie The Ramones she was
in that mix so she's part of like that
history but no one knows her music see
everybody talks about those bands like
they were the greatest bands but in the
70s nobody gave it a bunch of bands no I
went to see nobody gave a [ __ ] that's
right
it's the Rock and Roll Hall of Fame like
they don't have Iron Maiden in the Rock
and Roll Hall of Fame they have all
these [ __ ] [ __ ] bands that like
from CBGB elaborate like what's like
would David Bowie or what are you saying
oh you picked the one guy I like David
Bowie anyway know that you know the
underground you know the trees know the
priestess Ida peace is overrated man
okay they were great and then they went
on that parade they were great and then
I think the I think Halford actually
from Arizona oh yeah well he's from
England he lives out here now okay
that's so the tax brackets but um no no
like in the mid-80s they went really
like MTV and they just lost the Reg and
I saw him on Ozzfest like 10 years ago
and I was and I was gonna leave they
were terrible I got free tickets I was
gonna leave I did I was so happy I did
were you drunk oh yeah over did you see
well no I wouldn't go to Ozzfest I
wouldn't do that but but I saw I saw Z
when he was still when he was still
playing with Randy Rhoads yeah what
after a racquetball game but I saw why
am i [ __ ] blanking right now please
tell this court use your phone if I had
two band Black Sabbath yeah I saw when
Van Halen opened for blacks ass oh that
was late 70s and you don't remember any
of it he remember most here's some court
knowledge here's some quarter via court
saw Led Zeppelin live Oh April 1977 well
he said he's 74 but I was also I was
also a Garcia's fortieth birthday at the
zoo amphitheater in Oklahoma City Raul
Garcia who went to high school Jerry
Garcia ok yeah now that was a good time
cuz we had done some we did some Snoopy
acid we were driving from Stillwater
doses brand of acids so Snoopy was
blotter acid so that was like this
little blotter acid and the Allman
Brothers were opening with the opening
band and so we all did bought or asked
the opening band to play for nine hours
yeah and the dead exactly and so we we
drove down there and we took it like 45
minutes out thinking it would just be
kickin in
we pulled in so we got there were like
30 minutes in the show we don't feel
with the acid math never works out does
it never works out so we buy some little
we buy some barrel acid at the show and
right as we put it in our mouth and as
soon as it dissolves everybody kind of
looks to each other and they go oh [ __ ]
[Music]
well it's new pee kicked in and it was a
long [ __ ] that always works out like
I can eat some more I don't know maybe
and then that's the last thing anyone
says for nine hours yeah there was bad
it was I mean it's good but it was bad
I've never done this ass if they get so
what's the blotter never done ask a lot
of waters I tried it once and I Paul
told me was no good water's on it yeah
like a little like a little square piece
of paper in there and then there's the
other kind that's like a pill pill yeah
I was on I had like one time we went or
we were all hanging out at this house
and this guy's called it white pearl he
said and it was a little square piece of
paper yeah I remember just putting it
there and if and I just I didn't that I
guess it was weak it kept me up all
night laughing like I was up all night
oh yeah but I was afraid I was afraid of
no but I was afraid of like all the
things people said because we had
friends that were like one kid just
[ __ ] had a meltdown he saw like a
[ __ ] leprechaun on a branch and [ __ ]
and like I didn't want to see that [ __ ]
that's all such bullsh
ya don't understand in a leprechaun
movie yeah that's probably the worst I
know that well that that's like you know
acid man you need I should just do that
I should really do that for a living I
should be like a professional like take
people on their own trips yeah like yeah
like do it in the Love Boat no because
you really yeah you need when you're
tripping you need you need you need
stimulus you need things to do you they
need to be outside organized are you
need to be the concert at the beach it's
the times when you're in someone's
living room and like hey that's let's
ghost those are the times when it gets a
little hairy I don't really know this
guy you don't have enough your mind has
nowhere to go but inside yeah we did it
we did that one time in a guy's house in
college and we all freaked out so bad we
we wouldn't use the door we thought the
door was like went to hell so everyone
would everyone
every everyone would climb in and out of
the window so if you had to go outside
we'd climb out the window and we went to
get beer like we ran out of beer and you
can't run out of booze so way we cut me
in my roommate climbed out the window
and we got outside and we were like
freaking out because we were outside and
we thought you know and we almost got
arrested at the we went to this place
called a buy and buy which is like a
7-eleven okay yeah we were laughing so
[ __ ] hard that we like put the beer
on the thing and then we we kept having
trouble with the money and we just kept
going
just give it just give us just give it
off back to us give it all to us and he
thought we meant give him all the money
like we were robbing the place and we
started laughing and we couldn't stop so
we had to [ __ ] run out of the [ __ ]
bye-bye we left our money there let me
get the beer no beer there dude we is a
bad trip was a bad trip I tripped -
somebody laced weed me and my buddies
all skipped high school and we took a
trip in his Riviera down to New York
City from from upset about an hour north
and we think we're so cool listening to
[ __ ] wu-tang clan and we picked up a
[ __ ] hitchhiker oh Jesus and the
hitchhiker gave us in payment a bag of
weed and I was like dude I don't know if
we should do it and we did it we smoked
it that night and all I remember was
smoking this weed and getting to a point
that I really never got and I was
staring at the pattern of the floor and
then I looked up at my buddy's face and
he goes you all right and I don't know
and I just went back to the pattern of
the floor and I looked up at his face
and the pattern of the floor was on his
face and I go dude and I had a full
fledge [ __ ] meltdown on it I don't
know what it was my heart was jacked up
I had to lay on the couch and do that he
had to like [ __ ] talk me through it
because what we doesn't do that like I
don't know if those PC if you know I
think PCP gives you energy doesn't like
this [ __ ] me yeah yeah turned you in
the leg yeah no I just like the pattern
and I didn't know if I was staring at
the pattern of the floor for five
minutes
or four [ __ ] three hours and he was
just like dude you're gonna be alright
and like he was like the voice of reason
but I got I was [ __ ] I got time time
continuum is one of the things that
asses screws around with because I think
I've told the story on the podcast but I
sound like a scientist well I was after
a dead show in Buffalo one time
it's funny cuz we walked in and this guy
put a puddle in my hand and I just
tripped my balls off in my bed my
buddies I'm in the bathroom like okay
and he knew when he we waved to me like
goodbye
he knew I'm coming back in a police car
like a Tarantino movie we know how it's
gonna end so I had no ID so then he left
whatever not like oh whatever
so I'm a B B's hometown actually Buffalo
rich Stadium so you know we parked we
camped somewhere near bikes it's like
the statement buffle is like out like in
like a park it's not like in a city so I
didn't know where where I was at
someone I met some chicks hung up and I
know with him too like five in the
morning then like they're like okay well
we're like you're not staying with us
anymore like you gotta leave so I'm like
okay
so I'm walking around like I have no
idea so that I did the smart thing I got
rid of all my drugs because I know I'm
gonna get picked up right you know so
then they come over to guys like I'm
like guy goes oh hey what's going on oh
hey I don't know he's like other where
you at where you stay where you stay
they go I totally told the cop and this
is when I was like 2 to 65 like all
muscle really like it's why this one was
Indian Joe for real and I go dude
I go just just just lock me up ya know
well I was just like there got me up or
not yeah I was like dude I go I don't
know where I go you're my only hope to
find my way out of here I go you can
arrest me whatever you want to do like
I'm never gonna find my car man I'm like
I'm gonna walk around forever because
now he goes you come with me and then I
know where it's at and I go I know where
you're at I go oh whatever I go you're
my only hope man so then I literally I
literally sat in the back with his dog
his dog was cool with the car so then we
go this is in Hazzard County
yeah so then we go we get there and then
they go whatever and I'm thinking I
don't know whatever I was just tripping
so hard on my own [ __ ] what can I do
so then they're like then then they're
they made me wait forever where I
thought either get arrested or you know
how you go you know you know what's
going on maybe I really [ __ ] up maybe
here like a year you know just keeping
me held without any phone call yeah so
so so so then they go no were stop
Buffalo
and brought the project up so I go so
anyway so they go okay so we're coming
here it will get a couple tests so they
gave me a couple tested to my eyes a
couple of things and by then I was
really just kind of like fed off then I
was anger me so I'm like okay they go
we'll shut your eyes for twenty second
and tell us when it's twenty seconds and
then open them so I'm there and I'm like
[ __ ] these pigs like I've been seeing
here like all sober up by the time it's
done my eyes are gonna be shut for I
thought my eyes are shut for like three
hours I open him up I thought it was
really long I thought it was forever
like I thought all they mess they left
me here I don't care I was just like so
does the insensitive training audience
no how about this the legend of this
man's drinking oh yeah they know right
oh wait if they didn't they know from
the first 15 minutes of this podcast we
speak we speak well of Joe's drinking
yeah and you do something Joe does
something that's really rare when
somebody drinks the way he drinks cuz I
I mean I did say I did I mean I
performed a married dude in Sacramento
this man drank in front of my face in
front of my face he drank eight glasses
eight glasses sixteen ounce glasses of
Crown Royal and ice and he just kept
going dude are we staying like he was
doing one of those things cuz I was
talking to the Booker there potentially
to shoot my out my album there a dozen
15 and I'm just talking to the guy about
the venue and Joe's going are we good
you know when they people do that I'm
just gonna I'll get it let me just you
know and he just and I'm just like glass
of [ __ ] iced tea and I mean when he
was with the Queen I mean he used to do
a bottle a bottle of Crown a night
what's the Queen what are you talkin
right yeah when he was at Lampanelli
it's known that he would do you know he
had his crown every night right yeah it
was funny because Lisa's Ryder with like
Ryder was amazing in her room
before she on her health kick her room
looked like a sizzler really oh yeah so
was there a salad bar yes I mean is a
huge a huge spread you know right Matt
knows but ice cream ice cream we walk
Matt um and then I'm in my room was
literally like a big bottle of crown and
a little cooler with like two bottled
waters and two cokes hello
there's Joel no time with Joel on Monday
night up in Hollywood it's not good for
the podcast but yeah sorry
no that's the case we were talking oh we
talked about my yeah somebody said today
if if bartnik and ric flair ever were
able to drink together this the universe
there would just be change yeah I would
be like a black hole well this is this
well I I think we can we can tell the
story without naming names and we can
tell the story so literally a friend of
mine bill bill is built bill is friends
with Ric Flair
I'm giving secrets away Bill's friends
with Ric Flair so bill was in Atlanta he
didn't go to Ric Flair's party for the
three of 3430 he got a new phone so he
lost Flair's number so a radio friend of
mine in Pittsburgh Marc mad and he's
friends with Flair so he goes I call
Matt and get Flair's number and I'm
thinking Matt Matt's not gonna give me
Flair's number that's like giving me
like be naked pictures your wife we say
like comedians on the rock stars Kimmy's
gonna be wrestlers super funny super fly
Snuka yeah that was my bad was my big
he's in jail did he know he killed as he
killed him he killed his girlfriend but
she had it coming
judge martynuk resides no lot of meat
not me - no no like he threw her down
and she hit her head but he didn't mean
to kill her
any only do a jump Italy was on the
third step when he jumped what's so
funny was he was Roddy Piper smash the
cookies overhead that's the picture of
the paper what can I do it's
entertaining is fun she read the script
[Laughter]
no no the truth was here's the truth is
that he he whatever he he whatever he
did he did it wrong and then and then
you killing somebody anymore I mean
listen I don't like it was his fault I
mean it was his fault he was exist that
would have never happened
yes well I mean at that Days Inn in
Scranton oh hi in Scranton Pennsylvania
no he pushed her he pushed her something
and she hit her head
but then she lives like but then like
she lived a couple of days and and
nothing was he was not charged or
anything like there was like Oh was an
accident and then like 30 years later
when he wrote his autobiography he's
like I was all [ __ ] up but I [ __ ]
threw her down and [ __ ] smacked her
head and she never came back and that's
how they [ __ ] found out and that's
when they went the rest of them but then
they're like he's like gonna die anyway
but that's the whole reason like he that
happened that many years later yeah yeah
yeah he did it like in the 70s party
they'd never write in a book well you
got to read one I mean yeah I never read
that slick a book though Jim Ross has a
new book I thought I loved wrestling
when it was like real but fake you know
whenever like they weren't seen in the
same I was saying today I was saying
today I was like you know I didn't I
didn't get to watch Ric Flair because I
was I grew I was really young in the 80s
and when you turn on the TV especially
in the Northeast it was Hogan it was the
Ultimate Warrior
it was all that dude I
when I was a kid when I was a kid in the
70s we used to go to the lake and we got
this like channel that was from Dallas
Texas and they had Saturday night
wrestling on and that what was that was
that was that was the the Von Erich
brothers von erich the Von Erich
brothers it was the be Andre the Giant
is that that's not WCW that's WWF that's
world class Championship Wrestling from
the Sportatorium the Von Erich family
yes it was like this was Jimmy Superfly
Snuka this was junk yard oh it was like
its own thing it was its own see yeah
they all had their own look yeah it was
they all had territories but like Snuka
Andre there was like five or six guys
that were so big they would go anywhere
they wanted but they would have yeah
yeah they were this was this was live
from this was live from Dallas Texas or
somewhere in Texas and we thought it was
absolutely 100% real we literally we
never thought for a minute I know it was
kind of real no no people are getting
their heads but there's nothing real no
[Music]
but in those days it was really like
like if they were in a bar they had to
fight everyone in the bar to prove they
were tough and if they lost they got
fired like they weren't allowed to be in
the same cars together they would they
would wear I think they were wear masks
so like it or disguised as if they were
in like in the same plane together so
like right it was like totally like you
know it was a new story when Sheik and
what's-his-name were in the same car
yeah it was hacksaw jim duggan Deducer
knows oh yeah wrestling trivia Johnny
Bench it's why we would literally walked
every single human being except the two
people paid to sit here yeah is it my
drinking stories no instead of free
tickets the carbon bright sure was here
two speedos it before it forty people
listening you know sober didn't give a
[ __ ] about anything now he's sober
usually he's got to hang out close the
shades and I'm fine any more [ __ ] for
better or not nameste like that hell
namaste
well I think it's funny that they all
made it competitive it's like it's yoga
you know what no going back to the
wrestling thing when I was a little when
I was a little I was young the greatest
match I ever saw was because now it
turning
[ __ ] what comedy is it's like every
[ __ ] buddy's doing it but there was
like a smaller circuit but it was Ricky
the dragon steamboat versus macho man go
ahead watch that the long [ __ ] that
was just like and I was just little
watching it and they're [ __ ] bleeding
and when one goes down you're like it's
gonna be over the other one would just
come up and it was [ __ ] awesome dude
it was awesome it was when wrestling was
the best 770's on a black-and-white
television in my in my grass and my
grandmother's kitchen
Larry's abisco took a chair to Bruno
Sammartino and Blythe him the death of a
chair
my grandmother was throw-in Italians in
especially a Pittsburgh it literally
goes the Virgin Mary Joe DiMaggio Bruno
Sammartino and then Frank or Dean
whoever your favorite was that that's
the big four so Bruno
my grandmother saying like in the Venus
abisco goes to hell you know it was like
amazing bit of the chair and in the
plane Shea Stadium they saw that Shea
Stadium this podcast makes me want to
drink get violent and like do blow all
at the end a night is very know I'm here
one night man
come on out feet is this live Joe the
people can hear it on the Internet yeah
Brussels Phoenix I will I will I was
gonna break his beer-drinking record
tonight Southwest tonight away he's
gonna climb up on the third rung at the
Tempe improv and belly flop on top of
mercy while he closes out I will wrestle
any woman under 150 pounds at the improv
tonight and I'll wrestle any woman under
110 tonight fight you brother know we're
talking about Buffalo rich Stadium no
Joe rich Stadium how it's out in the
woods yeah you're from Buffalo okay cool
Bills fan yeah
did the cops have dogs have dogs no I
got I got picked up after a dead show in
Buffalo see if the story checks out it's
full charge investigation and
well I'm alright so how like with us to
leave uh they told me we're getting
picked up at 7:00 though no we're
getting picked up at 8:00
no no shows it it they say we're getting
picked up at 7:00 we'll do ten more
minutes you guys we're tonight Ricky and
I were to Tempe improv you know it's
it's big I mean we got a we got a I got
a full calendar I got this this show
tonight and then something like
Wednesday night at like 4:15 in the
afternoon so well I was pizookie quickly
state fails but her plane was delayed
plane fail oh boy yeah plane trap travel
fails parts unknown Anthony Bourdain
what the Pittsburgh my hometown isn't
that crazy
you put potatoes on a sandwich you mean
french fries and coleslaw that's what I
say yes you're mocking are you walking
our cuisine Little Italy in Pittsburgh
can hold up against any Little Italy
country well you guys you guys because
you guys travel a lot with birth and
I've heard on the birth podcast about
you too when you would go into these
delis and all you would [ __ ] talk
about is how great the [ __ ] salami or
how great you guys her admitted BER was
jealous he admitted he was jealous that
he wasn't Italian admitted it because
couldn't talk about the sausages we were
buying me one of the funniest things
that ever happened on the bus tour is
like three years ago
me and Joe I wish I was too long that
booked me we we go to Little Italy and I
mean Joe remember how I was looking they
had the fresh blocks of cheese but like
fresh blocks and they were cutting it
with like the two-handed [ __ ] slice
oh the paper sharp wrote the Pittsburgh
shot provolone burn treaty with Frank
Sinatra and the streets that flows into
it was like you died and went to like
the guy cuz Guinea heaven it was
incredibly guy cutting the sharp
provolone was doing it real slow like 15
his muscles out
verse he was tear rolling down is not
like his daughter was getting married so
I find this like Italian loaf of bread
and it was the softest freshest thing
and I just hand it to Joe and Joe just
squeezes it and
looked at me and we just had this like I
Italian eye conversation he didn't even
say where he just nodded he just goes
forget about and that was it and it was
just and we told ver and we got birdies
olives with these garlic knots
yeah you can believe he could not
believe it but you could do it in olive
I'm like when Italians see and olive
they see an opportunity and the whole
time and the whole time there's just
like Sopranos music like playing over
the over the whole thing everyone kept
going the back asking the boss for a
favor
oh it was but Berbers II spent eighty
nine dollars in in in Dublin sandwich I
spent 30 just on a pound of prosciutto
to go back to the bus we had the
greatest tour bus like a whole pig in
there Evelyn I'm being told I have to
leave gentlemen I'm like that show
solutely don't want me there they
literally don't want me on that trail
are we okay we're all right listen let's
end the [ __ ] podcast that's without
ending it we've had a good time guys
it's just so much fun to have version
thanks Paul virzi thanks for being here
full charge let them do their plugs yeah
uh you could actually this well this is
live right now yeah so if you got an
hour go to the Tempe improv I'll be
there at eight o'clock with so many
funny people tomorrow night on the
eleven o'clock show I will be at
stand-up live in Phoenix and Saturday
night flying back to New York to work
with this gentleman Joe Barton I will be
at laugh it up comedy club in
Poughkeepsie New York it's gonna be a
blast so come out to that and for other
date you could check Paul virzi com
okay mr. Potro we get stand-up live
tonight on Ari Shaffir is podcast at
9:30 I'll be doing stand-up at midnight
at stand-up live the full charge Power
Hour tapes at 12 noon tomorrow
and then stand-up live again at midnight
tomorrow night Throckmorton thenor
Theatre in Mill Valley I've never played
it but I'm playing it on December 12
nice Oh dirty dog that's a great room
Thanks all right uh Mike Mike my dates
are all my stuff
come see me with virzi give the website
yeah Joe Barton calm go to court McGowan
calm it's all there this isn't
sensitivity training I'm court McGowan
I'm Joe Buck Nick have a great
wait I was talking you through your acid
trip